[Music]
our first question is who composes the
remnant church
is it only seven-day adventists
who are or rather what are the defining
characteristics of the remnant and what
is its purpose
let's get a broad view of what remnant
might mean in isaiah chapter 1 verse 2
isaiah says hear o heavens and give here
o earth for the lord has spoken
i have nourished and broughted children
and they have rebelled against me the ox
knoweth his honor and he asks his master
scribd
but israel does not know my people does
not consider
a
sinful nation
a people laden with iniquity a seed of
evil doers children like corrupters they
are forsaken the lord they provoke the
holy one of israel they've gone away
backward now isaac is described in the
spiritual condition of the israelites
sinful nation a people living with
iniquity a seed of evil doers children
that are corrupters
from the soul of the foot even unto the
head there's no soundness in it but
wombs and bruises and putrifying source
that's how he describes israel this is
god telling him to use these words
in verse nine the situation is so dire
in verse 9 the bible says except the
lord of hosts had left unto us a very
small remnant
we should have been a sodom and we
should have been as gamora in other
words there was a small group that did
not fit the description in verse 4 as
sinful nation of people laden with
iniquity a seed of evil doers children
that are corrupters there was a small
group who lived differently they were
faithful to god and so and they
preserved by the power of god and their
operation of course and so the bible
says except the lord of hosts had left
unto us a very small remnant let's
continue the chapter to understand where
the remnant or how the remnant fits
verse 15 when you spread forth your
hands i will hide my eyes from yay when
you make many prayers i will not hear
your hands are full of blood
wash you make you clean put away the
evil of your doing from before my eyes
cease to do evil verses 15 16 and verse
17 learn to do well seek judgment
relieve the oppressed judge the
fatherless plead for the widow do what
is right clearly then the remnant in
verse 9 refers to that small group that
was doing what is right in the sight of
god as outlined in his holy word and so
the remnant from the advertised
perspective which is a biblical one the
remnant refers to that small group
less that is still faithful to thus set
the lord and with respect to these last
years we're talking about the three
angels messages and all that that
expression encompasses the remnant that
small group still clinging to the faith
which was once delivered unto the saints
and so revelation 12 17 tells us and the
dragon was rough with a woman and went
to make war with the remnant of her seed
which keep the commandments of god and
the testimony of jesus christ
now in verse chapter 13 of revelation i
stood up on the sand in the sea and saw
a beast rise up out of the sea the
dragon now seems to be looking for the
two uh
agents which he will use the sea beasts
of revelation 13 1 through 10 and the
two horned beasts revelation 13 11
through 18 the dragon and those two will
combine to try to overthrow the remnant
not the entire bolt of cloth just the
remnant because it is the remnant as in
the case of the days of isaiah isaiah 1
9 there were a few who were not
described as sinful nation laid with
iniquity cedarville evil doers children
that are corrupted the small remnant
holding on to god's messages as
entrusted to them
are what we understand as the remnant
today now that question has several
parts what's the second part of it
okay so the second part was is it only
seventh day adventist which i think
you've covered
okay let but let me let me deal with
that directly
the remnant is described in revelation
12 revelation 14 revelation 12 17 and
the dragon was wrath with the woman and
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed which keep the commandments of god
and the testimony of jesus christ so we
have those two defining characteristics
we add to that revelation 14 verse 12
because this is also an end time because
the the the
jeff right after that is the coming of
christ in revelation 14. so we're
dealing with the end-time people here is
the patience of the saints they are they
that keep the commandments of god and
the faith of jesus and so we have the
commandments of god the testimony of
jesus the faith of jesus these are the
distinguishing marks of the remnant
people of god and remember there are a
small group from a larger whole
now are they only seven they haven't
just i cannot come boldly and say they
are only seventy address i will say the
remnant i describe that those who keep
the commandments of god that have the
testimony of jesus christ and the faith
of jesus christ those are the ones that
are counted as the remnant but i must
add according to john 10 verse 16 of the
sheep i have which are not of this fold
they are in babylon that is the that's
the target group for the loud cry of
revelation 18 1-5 come out of her my
people god has people in babylon now
they're not keeping the commandments
they're disobedient ignorantly so they
need to be informed that they may now
practice remnant behavior and so in a
certain sense there are
those who are god wants to bring into
the remnant there are some preachers who
say the remnant refers to the visible
and the invisible when i pick no large
coral with them what i'm saying is the
remnant is described as those who keep
the commandments of god have the
testimony of jesus and the faith of
jesus we cannot say that those in
babylon are doing that even though god
sees in the heart of those persons is a
desire for truth so they are called out
that they may come and be a part of the
remnant and so the remnant are those
described in revelation 12 17 14 12 but
god has others who have a heart for the
teachings of the remnant and he will
call them and they will come because my
sheep know my voice
amen amen see the world is divided into
obedient disobedient ultimately
those who obey and those who don't
now
so it's not dividing between an
advertiser not an advertisement it's
divided between those who obey and those
who don't
there's some who obey actively there's
some who have a heart to obey they just
don't have the knowledge and they need
to be given that knowledge through the
loud cry
which will be energized by the latter
rain by the way
but those who make that loud cry will be
those who are using the former rain with
those using the early rain using the
former rain will be the ones who will
receive the latter and to give that loud
cry it has to be loud because the noise
the false ever in babylon is so loud
that the loud try has to out loud the
largeness of babylon and so it's a loud
cry that people can hear
for instance if you look down to history
all the reformers virtually all identify
the papacy as a little horn the man of
sin the sea beast all of them virtually
yet it does not seem to sink in so we
need a loud loud to crash through the
high decibels of error that are causing
people to go off in all kinds of
directions it has to be loud and those
in the heart for the remnant will come
amen amen and you know ellis i believe
that's a perfect segue into our next
question
you